through the favelas of rio de janeiro a
funeral procession
for two little girls
the cries of mourners heavy not just
with grief but with rage
a devastated community watched on as
their coffins were buried
rebecca beatrix rodriguez dos santos was
seven years old
her cousin emily victoria silva dos
santos was just
four both killed by stray bullets as
they played in the street
emily's father sealed her grave with his
own hands
his fury palpable
and that's because this family blamed
the police for these deaths
they say they saw officers firing into
the community and they want justice
a police officer that says he's prepared
and should protect us
and then shoots in the direction of four
small children
i can't get it straight in my mind my
head i really can't understand this
police operations in rio favelas are an
almost daily occurrence
and almost always violent
the criminal drug gangs they seek are
well armed but the people living here
are poor
and too often caught in the crossfire
one charity claims 22 children have been
hit just this year
eight have died
in general it is boys and girls that
live in favelas who die
that's why these deaths are ignored by
the authorities
the police deny involvement this time
but it's unlikely to wash
in these embattled communities they say
officers shoot first and ask
questions second and it's costing the
most innocent of lives
helena smith sky news